the music and festive atmosphere soon
attracts a crowd
this safe puani theater group is
performing today in bomani in southern
kenya
[Music]
the play is about everyday hardship
environmental issues and climate change
it's called miyongo that means decades
in swahili
it sweeps through the last 40 years
starting in 1981 when nature here was
still intact
but years of deforestation have followed
to feed the charcoal industry
what will things look like in the future
group manager david kalumi takes the
audience on a journey where did we go
wrong he asks what can we do differently
to ensure the next 10 years will be
better the story ends in the year 2031.
it just put people on the mirror for
them to see that this is exactly what
i'm doing so what can i do so theater
has been it's just a reflection of their
life so from the reflection you can
understand now it's like a mirror if you
have a something uh that on your face
then it's time for you now to try to
clear the dirt so this is exactly what
we're doing
safe puani's activists know people here
are faced with existential problems
only three months ago 40 year old chaka
majaliwa settled in this village a
two-hour drive from mombasa with his 50
cattle
but now his herd is dying of starvation
he used to live in a village some 35
kilometers away until drought forced him
to leave
but the situation is no better here
i have to buy the calves milk because
their mothers have no milk to suckle
them
they don't even have the strength to
stand up
they don't have the energy to graze on
the field spa screen
chaka majaliwa has to help them up
today he's assisted by some of david
kalumi's actors currently touring the
area
we're here because we are
working on a program on environment
mostly what we're doing is looking at
community resilience towards climate
change as we can see that
the weather patterns are changing
we can see
that the climate is not as it was some
years back
for one the dry season is getting longer
sometimes it doesn't rain for months on
end now
the theater group has invited locals to
a workshop to talk about their troubles
the team hopes participants can pass on
what they learn here to other villagers
living conditions will be better
and that will keep people healthier
the retired civil servant has planted a
range of trees from casuarinas to blue
gum and neem trees
they provide shade and protect the
ground from drying out
he also keeps bees
he has 18 hives and earns the equivalent
of 1 600 a year
that allows him to pay for his
daughter's schooling and soon he hopes
for her university education too
one of his two wives and the mother of
his three sons kapipi kalawa had no
a fate shared by most women around here
poverty is widespread
locals fell trees to clear the land for
agriculture but that makes the ground
even drier so harvests are poor
they end up resorting to selling
charcoal but that's made from trees so
they locked in a vicious circle
in the workshops facilitated by parent
ngo safe kenya the safe puani team helps
locals develop alternatives
we believe that
is the people who
first of all
started the problem and it's the people
who can solve their own problem so to us
is us now coming to just make them
realize this is where we went wrong
and then after there is them now to look
at the solutions and how to ours is only
to facilitate these discussions
facilitate them coming together that is
what we are doing much but the solution
is coming directly from the people
after two months of consultations and
conversations the theater group's latest
tour is drawing to a close now
the safe kenya ngo aims to boost
people's resilience amid the climate
crisis and inspire them to find
solutions
its safe pani theater group is based in
mombasa and financed by the
international climate initiatives small
grants program
they'll continue to work with locals
here for the next two years
the audience have got the message
i have learned that when we manufacture
charcoal
it has many negative effects on our land
[Music]
things will change because there will be
no more cutting down of trees
and if people get tree seedlings they
will plant them and the current
situation will improve
is also among the audience
his tree planting has often been mocked
by his neighbors
now he's been vindicated
though in fact he's desperate since the
activists were last here the drought has
killed all of his bees and the seedlings
for his new plants have dried up
still he's determined to keep planting
new trees and hopes more villagers will
follow his lead
it's the only way they can secure their
future
you